en face du château de versailles aux
grandes écuries royales un camion orange
en sont fort simulateur casque de
réalité virtuelle écrans interactifs on
est venus en bus et maintenant on va
découvrir les métiers etc au vrai j'ai
appris plein de trucs c'est intéressant
c'est pour faire vivre l'expérience donc
dans les kiosques 3d on va voir par
exemple des métiers comme élagueurs pour
vraiment faire vivre le métier de
l'intérieur et ont une expérience
immersive et on a réussi
un test pour faire de la conduite
d'engins agricoles donc voilà c'est
vraiment immersif des outils pour
renseigner les jeunes aux métiers du
vivant mais pas seulement tout est
aujourd'hui
très très informatisée et il ya beaucoup
d'exploitants qui gèrent leur
exploitation de presque dans le bureau
et avec des écrans pour gérer la traite
des vaches
l'alimentation externe donc donc c'est
ça qui intéresse aussi des jeunes et et
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est vraiment très très technologique à
les drones il ya toutes ces choses là
qui sont aujourd'hui qui intéresse
énormément les jeunes les classes de
collèges et lycées sont divisés en deux
groupes l'un se focalise sur la pratique
l'autre échanges sur les métiers de
l'enseignement agricole qui assure
aujourd'hui 90 % d'insertion
professionnelle si demain les métiers
qu'on ne pense pas à trouver dans les
établissements agricoles ça va être le
service à la personne les filières de la
vente ça c'est des métiers qui sont
alors connu par ailleurs mais qu'on ne
trouve pas il faut qu'on ne pense pas
trouver là et après il ya des métiers
qui sont moins connus tout ce qui va
être viticulture par exemple
arboriculture un petit peu des sections
de la production mais spécifique après
son escale dans la cité royale le camion
mise en place par le ministère de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation se
rendra à chartres puis sera stationné à
paris porte de versailles pendant les
dix jours du salon international de
l'agriculture